chris doyle was uh
let go reached a separation agreement
technically 1.1 million
buyout at iowa last year allegations of
racist remarks and belittling of players
emerged
chris doyle emerged in jacksonville as
the new director of sports performance
peter urban meyer
who has a little bit of a history of
being around some coaches and some
players that
may or may not have been involved in
some behavior that may or may not be
regarded as acceptable in a civilized
society
i just look i know urban meyer's got a
ton of equity now in jacksonville
and they've handed him the full keys to
the operation
but but th this this move is the first
test
for him not just making the decision but
how he deals with the decision how he
lives with it whether he resents the
criticism
how the organization moves forward i was
surprised by this
because here's the thing and i'm not
saying that chris doyle should never be
employed again in any capacity anywhere
but so soon after what happened at iowa
for a job that there are surely plenty
of other eminently qualified individuals
i don't know why
the jaguars and why urban meyer would
would choose to make a move
like that and essentially put their hand
right into the middle of the fire
you know i agree mike this is uh
you know if you asked all available
assistant coaches at all levels college
pro
uh who had would have the chance to move
uh either their team would let them out
their contract was up
they were unemployed whatever it was
there's no question at all that
everybody
would have urban meyer very high on the
list for a simple reason
that urban meyer unless he pulls a nick
saban and quits after two years
urban meyer has got at least four years
of equity built up there he's not
getting fired
even if he has two really bad years at
the beginning
even a third bad year he is going to be
in that job for a little while unless
again
he chooses to go so what does that mean
that means that job security
is excellent if you're on the
jacksonville jaguars coaching staff
right now so if you're getting recruited
by the jaguars you could say to your
wife
hey look we're going to be there a while
we can put the kids in school
we can do this it's a great place to
live
great town all that and i agree with you
mike my first thought was
that first of all not only will he get
a lot of questions from people like us
but i wonder also if he's going to get
questions from players on his own team
you know word travels fast in the in the
player fraternity in the coaching
fraternity
are you saying that i didn't even look
at their roster are there no players
from iowa
on the jacksonville roster would they
maybe not even consider
choosing iowa players in the draft i
mean it's just
it opens a can of worms that i don't
understand why why it was open
well and the questions already have
begun we've got excerpts of the press
conference during which the crystal
questions did emerge
and meyer's response is here's some of
it
yeah i've known chris for uh close to 20
years our relationship goes back to when
i was at utah and he was the
number one strength coach and really he
he was doing sports performance before
sports performance became
a high priority in in college sports and
so
i've known him i've studied him uh we've
had a relationship
uh i vetted him thoroughly yeah no
reservations hiring him based on the
allegations and and what happened at
iowa and
why hire him instead of going in a
different direction oh sure i
i i vet everyone on our staff and like i
said the relationship goes back
close to 20 years and a lot of hard
questions asked a lot of vetting
involved and
with the with all our staff but uh we
we did a very good job vetting that one
so you're confident there's not going to
be any issues yeah they're all
very confident did you have to get
shad's permission
to hire him chris doyle uh shad was
involved with our high-end uh
hires and uh he was very he was involved
and are you at all concerned that him
being in the building will
impact your ability to attract free
agents
uh i if i was i wouldn't have hired him
uh once again i'll explain that if if
that becomes a
question the one thing i'm very
confident is that
i would imagine within a year or two of
the best sports performance team in the
national football league
one iowa player on the jaguars roster
currently cornerback greg
mabin um i i i
you're right peter word travels fast
players know each other word's going to
get around there were serious
allegations made
regarding chris doyle now he denied
making the comments but the end result
was an investigation that didn't name
names per se but it found that there was
belittling of players that there were
racially inappropriate comments made and
doyle left with a 1.1 million dollar
buyout
so uh a challenging situation and again
urban my and and it's just amazing how
this all just kind of gets forgotten
once a guy gets put on a pedestal by an
nfl team and it was clear from the
get-go this is the guy that shot khan
wanted to hire
but whether it was at florida whether it
was the stuff that happened at ohio
state
there's always been just something on
the fringe that urban meyer's been able
to keep
just beyond arm's length but that that
makes it even more curious
that he would welcome on to his staff
someone who's been involved in a
controversy because then
that that will get people like us to say
well let's look at some of the people
urban meyer has surrounded himself with
over the years
yeah you know mike the one other thing
is you were saying that
you know a head coach in a new
situation what what
this said to me this hire also said to
me
is that look i'm going to do things my
way
and i'm going to hire the people i want
to hire i think he made some
excellent hires the one hire that really
stood out to me
was joe cullen uh the defensive line
coach at baltimore
um who he hired as his defensive
coordinator
who you know in my opinion and he's been
very
upfront with this he had a
well-publicized uh battle with alcohol
early in his career
and met with roger goodell talked to him
had that weird incident in the
drive-through restaurant
and look the bottom line in the whole
thing is
people ought to get a chance to rebuild
their lives
and i totally get it joe cullen has
taken that chance
he's been an absolute total model
citizen
since that incident he's met with
goodell on several occasions but
this just really is different to me
because this is very fresh in our
memories
and and as i said so many people would
be after this job
it's just i think it's a very odd hire
to me mike because
it could it could deter
urban meyer if it deters him from
recruiting even two or three players
and and maybe it will maybe it won't i
don't know but if it deters him from
recruiting players basically what
why is he there and and you know the
reality is
and this gets into that same type of
confidence delusion
hubris that a great quarterback has a
great coach believes he's always going
to find a way to say the right thing
put out the fires and ultimately
rely on that person who brings a certain
element of controversy
to assist in the broader cause of making
the team as good as
it can be so we'll see how that plays
out for the jaguars they've got a busy
day today they'll be checking out trevor
lawrence as he throws for scouts
before he has surgery on his
non-throwing shoulder
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports